flipper flop stars Christina and Tarek  el Moussa make a public appearance  together amid pending divorce  family always comes first clearly with  these two business comes first the  former pair made their first public  appearance together since announcing  their split in December showing a united  front on friday at the 2017 investors  summit in Las Vegas Nevada flipping  houses is our passion both the HGTV  stars shared photos of each other  together at the event to social media  they also took pictures with their  students who came to learn about the art  of flipping houses a source close to  Christina recently told ET the two are  quote currently in production for season  7 it's business as usual and they remain  committed to their children and  co-parenting the former couple shared  two children together six-year-old  daughter Taylor and one-year-old son  Brayden  you